two people that died were riding in a
2021 polaris slingshot similar to this
recently there have been several
terrible crashes involving high-end
rentals
madison kimbrough joins us live near the
strip and the i-15 tonight with a
reminder as a lot of visitors are in
town this weekend and take extra caution
on those roads madison
i'm here live at desert inn and i-15 as
you can see there are plenty of cars out
here zipping through if you you're
heading out tonight be careful watch
your speed and don't drink and drive so
you or someone else doesn't become
another statistic
it's up so much not just compared to
last year but on this decade we're now
on track for the deadliest year since
2007. we've seen a lot of similarities
between impairment
lack of seatbelt usage
speed
and again those are all decisions that
are being made behind the wheel by these
individual drivers
a shocking trend as nevada highway
patrol and metro report an alarming
number of vehicle fatalities this year
you have a lot of out of town visitors
and they're just distracted they have
rental cars it's not a surprise seeing
how people
drive really fast not paying attention
saturday morning's crash in red rock a
reminder of how careful drivers need to
be a couple from out of town lost their
lives after driving too fast in a
high-end sports car it's still unclear
if it was indeed a rental we have seen
the trend with luxury rentals and people
choosing to come to our our state and
especially southern nevada and speed and
that's a deadly combination we expected
that fatalities were going to go down in
2020 with you know everybody did people
taking advantage of the open roads
speeding driving impaired a lot more
that's definitely translating to 2021
but it's more dangerous because we have
more people on the roadways
according to the national highway safety
administration there are projecting
364 fatalities this year statewide
that's compared to last year where it
was 314.
reporting live from desert inn and i-15
madison kimbrough live local now